hey everyone de Volo here and today we
are back for our fourth Excursion into
the American wilderness for the next
part of steelball run here we finally
start to find out who and where chy
zelli might be from along with a
possible reason for him even joining the
race to begin with so far he's just
appeared as more of this like brutish
character that can take any challenge
hit on but throughout the short Arc all
of that is challenged and both of the
guys are forcing a situation that begins
to bring out a new side of them
subscribe if you guys are new around
here and push this video to 5K likes but
either way sit back and relax as we
delve into the desert born Outlaws Arc
from hero Iraqi steel for
[Applause]
[Music]
run back inside of the second stage it's
almost sunset time 6:30 p.m. Johnny and
gar have traveled a distance of about 95
km on the first day across the desert
and are now left with only 50 km or so
until the nearest watering hole the
current rank is first while camping at
the SE location as the Joo is stationed
up around their fire goo I'm assuming
tells Johnny about a 9-year-old boy
named Marco his family belonged to a
line of servants to the aristocrats
Marco was also supposed to serve under a
baron called Rippy and had to clean
their hats and shoes when the 9-year-old
Marco's time of separation from his
parents came he was given a hopeful
message by his father his father said
that this job will bring him happiness
as long as he stays humble and
hardworking because of this every Dawn
Marco would wake up and brush the hats
and the boots of the baron and his
guests however the baron was plotting a
Sinister plan to overthrow and
assassinate the king luckily the King's
assassination was prevented but treason
is an extremely serious crime for people
who F over absolute power all of The
Baron's partners and the plot along with
their families as well were all put on
trial and sent to execution for this act
from the evidence found the
assassination plot was planned in The
Baron's estate and because Marco was
seen as a part of their family even
though he was just a servant who shined
shoes they assumed that there was no
doubt that he knew the method of
execution was beting and the state's
decision is absolute anyways while I'm
guessing a big guar was telling Marco's
story or I completely misinterpreted
that and Johnny had read about the story
beforehand and this was just like a
recap of it Johnny managed to spin the
cork of the champagne bottle that he
carried with him all of the time
watching it catch speed inside of his
hand he then watches as it travels up
his arm before shooting off Johnny
wanted gyro to watch him so an
astonishment he screams out asking if he
was gyro though had a lot going on
inside of his head and just snapped back
asking why does he have to watch all day
not hearing and more concerned on the
spin himself Johnny realizes that the
cork disappeared and tries to find it he
searches under the gear place up against
the rocks and panics when he can't find
The Cork at all getting smacked in the
head though he looks up to see the
horse's ass and feels what he think
thinks is damp poo rolling down his back
when in all reality it's the cork that
I'm assuming will shot up the horse's
ass but the bottle's cork can't be that
important when you're camping in the
middle of the desert with a lit fire at
night time thus gyu senses a racer
coming towards them and he asks Johnny
to take out any weapons that he's kept
hidden Johnny tries to find the gun that
he's kept on him since the beginning of
the race but he's unable to find it
glancing over he notices jaru spelled
open bag in the weird case with a code
of arms inscribed on it seen an article
for a boy with a des sentence he looks
closer at the letter with the Cod of
arms on it curiously he wonders if G
stole it as to have a Cod of arms
without permission from a lord is a
illegal for someone inside of Europe
looking closer under the headline text
and seeing a title about 50 million
needed for a retrial Johnny comes to a
huge realization appearing right behind
him though jaru scolds Johnny for going
through his stuff then standing there
with an aura not seen yet from him jaru
just leans down grabs his bag and leaves
without saying a word Johnny tries to
explain that it was wasn't on purpose
still he questions who garro is as he
knows he's not from this country to
begin with again jarro just tells him to
stick to his own damn bag confused
Johnny just wondered why he didn't say
anything more on the subject he wanted
to know why why could G use these steel
balls what are his roots is he trying to
save that child all alone are they
related the race or that I dear Volo who
rewok inside of part seven she'll say
though is that the answer to these
questions will soon come once the
writers reach the high point in the race
in the meantime G points out that the
random Rider really is hitting their way
as slow dancer then throws Johnny off
his back jarro also states that the
balloons watching the race have landed
and this route might be an interference
AOW one he screams out trying his best
to make this racer stay away but to no
use as the dude continues riding forth
the guy like riding on the back of the
horse here is called Andre boom boom and
he yells back screaming that he means no
harm at all and just came all of us way
because we saw a fire in the distance
join the swollen fingers on his hand he
nervously explains that he was bitten by
a lizard when he was trying to take a
dump and now it's resulted in his
swollen fingers seeing him getting off
his horse now Johnny asks like what the
hell he's up to and questions what
exactly he was bitten by screaming back
that it was a poisonous yellow and black
striped lizard he pleads with him to let
him use the campfire to burn the wound
and clean it jarro thinks that he could
be faking it but Johnny knows that the
spotted salamander has a dangerous Venom
and once it circles through the dude's
body he will undoubtedly die Johnny asks
if he's just going to let the dude die
but since gyro just can't seem to trust
this dude's story he doesn't know
however he does offer the random a piece
of burning wood to go ahead and start
his own campfire or seize the wound
thankful for having his life saved this
mentally deranged racer then took off
his belt wrapped it around his neck
flipped it over a tree then dropped to
the ground so that the connection
tightened creeped out with like what the
hell is up to G questions Andre's
actions Andre is just like bro what are
you on about this is anesthesia and he
needs a painkiller for what he is about
to do plus he invented this trick the
feeling is absolutely insane and he lets
chicks tried on him all the time Jesus
Andre guys don't be like Andre and never
try that at home please don't try that
at home I would hate to see your mom
walking on that anyway Andre slices off
his poison fingers to stop it spreading
around his body however he still ends up
passing out because of the connection
around his neck seeing this jarro tosses
some fire to help Andre quickly seize
the wound while pointing out that the
Strangling might have also been too much
for him realizing that he's not moving
anymore and getting personal jro kicks
Andre's blade and apologizes for being
hard on him when he first arrived but he
had to be sure that he wasn't lying at
all seeing the guy foam from the mouth
Gyra really starts the question if the
man's even alive anymore Johnny speaks
up and lets his man know that his found
rac's name on the list he goes by Andre
boom boom under number
c450 and he's currently placed 10th in
the overall rankings glancing down at
his own boot though gyro just notices
how it's randomly being torn open
feeling that something just isn't right
with all of this he quickly looks around
trying to figure out what it could have
been before Johnny himself Cuts Jar's
thoughts off speaking up he notes that
also in ninth and 11th place is two
people with the surname boom boom which
in his eyes means that he's definitely
not alone and the family will be nearby
making pace and Galloping their way
towards our main Joo Johnny and G's
heads snap in the direction of two
quickly approaching Riders the female
begins crying wondering if her bro Andre
is dead her father though tells her to
shut her trap as me don't cry even
though she totally isn't a man and even
though gyro approached carefully Andre
is still currently giving it all that
he's got sadly for gyro he actually
touched Andre's knife yes it was never
directly with his skin but his boat did
touch the Blood Stained knife with those
mountain-shaped horse who's nearing
Johnny pulls out the blicky and
questions what the hell these guys are
up to jar knows for a fact that like
Johnny thought earlier this is a thre
Man team and they're all aiming for the
50 million so if they get in any closer
he needs to use that gun on the guy on
the left while gyro takes the dude on
the right randomly and before these
plans can get put into action though
bladed spikes shoot up piercing Gyro's
foot and taking him by surprise going to
clutch at his leg he explained to Johnny
that he doesn't know what the hell's
going on his leg just feels like it's
made of steel all of a sudden looking at
the Kos Andre Johnny wonders if it could
have been him or the two guys closing in
knowing that something's definitely
wrong inside of him jar can only think
of the time earlier we he had to kick
away Andre's knife with his foot and how
now it seemed like some kind of poison
had infected him as the boom boom family
came closer Johnny pulled out his pistol
but it was taken apart in a matter of
moment and the detached pieces werein
sent shooting into the side of Jar's
body changing direction all of the gun
pieces then jammed themselves onto Jar's
leg baffled with like what the hell he
just watching Johnny screams that it
wasn't an old gun like he hasn't even
used it that much but it just suddenly
fell apart when he took it out then on
top of that the rest of the gun is still
being pulled towards garro with Johnny
just being barely able to hold it back
looking at his wounds jarro can do
nothing as each part of the pistol
slowly starts to become one with his
flesh noticing the knife now spining in
his Direction Johnny screams that now
there is even moving towards him over
with the bone Boone family the sister
questions if Andre was able to get the
lizard venom out in time her father
though just just pissed that she was
being loud told her to split away from
him and make her strike from the
opposite angle while she's off following
those orders jny deduces that everything
traveling towards gyro is made from Iron
there's even iron inside of someone's
blood so maybe they can control iron
objects that way through some sort of
like metal manipulation flinging itself
up off the ground the knife is just
barely blocked by G's steel ball however
it still connects with his skin getting
stuck there seeing the father now
closing in jar flings his steel ball in
the dude's Direction and pH with a
rotating orb of metal Benjamin boom boom
pulls up his hand and captures the
ball's trajectory within his own fingers
reticle activating his ability Benjamin
stops the ball as it slams into a
figurative wall and begins getting
ground down in size watching him reach
out to grab the marblized steel ball now
Johnny can only mutter in horror that
the ball was ground down in midair
sticking with her like completing out of
Randomness the bonebone family's plan is
then out of the blue exposed by La who
revealed that her father planned to win
first place in the race her brother
would come in second and she would take
the third place meanwhile Johnny and
Gyro were still trying to figure out how
the steel balls got ground up in midair
they realized that the boom boom
family's power only works on iron so in
that case these steel balls have to be
made from lion eventually the two alive
boom boom family members surrounded
Johnny and Gyro in hopes of getting
their revenge for Andre jarro knows that
unlike Mrs Robinson from beforehand
these guys are nuts and there has to be
something Superior that's behind all of
this confused on what he means by
Superior jar can only explain to Johnny
that well he really doesn't know because
he doesn't actually have a clue himself
looking over at the mental case who
somehow woke back up Joe notices this
wacky looking lizard thing attached to
him wondering if Johnny also saw the
thing on Andre he instantly loses sight
of it himself and then on top of that
the bleeding on his leg begins worsening
as the parts start burrowing even deeper
jar knows that it's because they're now
surrounded by all three of them and the
closer he approaches them the stronger
the effect of iron in his leg becomes
pondering he knows that if these guys
end up right next to him then there's a
huge chance that the middle go straight
through him after literally Lolly
gagging with each other for a few
minutes over the other side of the
battlefield as they slowly restrict the
size of the circle Benjamin questions
who will be the one to actually fully
close in and land the finishing blows
Andre thinks that they might have some
more guns but Benjamin says he doesn't
think that plus it wouldn't even matter
if they did because of their ability
choosing to go himself Andre speaks up
stating that he's prepared to get
revenge for what happened earlier
pulling out his other steel ball and
activating the spin Andre speaks up and
points out that it's the other steel
ball unconcerned with like whatever gar
was actually planning La just thinks
it'll be the same as last time splitting
away from the group Andre screams that
it's time his family will take first
place in this race throwing the ball in
retaliation though Andre screams at gyro
that there's no way it's going to reach
him however it wasn't actually aimed at
him and instead he watched it as it flew
straight up into the sky watching it
fall back down now towards him Andre
activates his ability and screams that
there's no way it to reach him before it
hits gy will be laid out on the floor
dead as the ball slams back down right
next to Andre though completely missing
him a random rock is flipped up at a
perfect angle in the process knowing
that they only have power over iron jyu
presumed that a rock could be shot and
seeing that it was about to hit he
immediately told Johnny to pack his bags
and get on the horse as there's still
two of them to go and frankly these
people are freaking weird back over with
Andre it's Sean that as said by gyro a
rock was shot up off the ground at a
perfect angle that ripped a hole through
Andre and left his family stunned on the
steds and freaking Bo s it away from the
boom boom family now jar points out that
after they gained some distance from
them the damage is slowly dispersed
scene Johnny wonders if it was a trick
of some sort or did they actually use
something like a poison to make this
effect believing that it's something
more though jar points out how they
first made contact with him then
surrounded them before slowly closing in
to him it look like when you get stuck
in the middle of all three of the people
it creates a powerful attack which
attracts all iron in the vicinity to the
center almost like a massive Magnet
having gained some distance now Jo feels
like it's probably best to keep heading
towards the watering hole 50 km ahead to
get away from all current Danger back
with the boom boom family Andre reacts
in horror over the gaping hole while
simultaneously his just the scream that
the hole is even bigger than his
freaking belly button screaming and
filled with rage over his son's
impending death Benjamin pulls out his
revolver and fires a bunch of shots
towards the fleeing Riders en raging him
further La says that they're too far
away now and that their bullets are all
lit if they were iron then they might
have actually had a chance there not
done Ben then points his revolver at his
son and tells him to move slightly to
the right firing the BL with like
literally no concern at all for who was
on the receiving end Benjamin then uses
the blood covered bullets to rain
Andre's infused iron blood all over
Johnny as he tries to escape happy with
like what he achieved there Ben asks to
see Andre's wounds only to instantly
tell him to harden up as it's a tiny
hole back when he was young he fell off
a cliff and tore his whole freaking jaw
off and had to walk 5 km home that hole
in comparison is just like nothing still
needing to taste Revenge Ben explains
that their plan is to make it through
Watering Hole faster than anyone else
and if they get there first they'll
destroy it so if any other races come by
then they'll also be wiped out because
they won't have any other water since
they obviously just got lost by johonny
and Gyro though Ellie wonders how in the
world they meant to catch up to them but
Ben if the big brain reveals that it
won't be them doing the chasing instead
he plans to have the guy tracking them
find the Joo La asks who it is and Ben
reveals that since this morning someone
figured out their tracks and has been
following them ever since Blown Away
with a skill it would take to track
someone through horse Hooves Andre asks
who it could possibly be Ben states that
he can't exactly see from here but it's
most likely a sheriff possibly even
Mountain Tim who he heard is good
friends with the sheriff in preparation
for Mountain Tim Ben uses his control
over iron to manipulate the plates
within his face while watching their
father go through an excruciating
transformation Andre speaks up as he
thinks he's figured out what big pops is
planning to do Ben on the other hand
reveals their past Journey stating that
they were looking for mines on the
Cursed Mountain and side of the desert
all of the Indians despised that
mountain but they gained power and ever
since then they've only been happy so if
anyone tries to stop there they will
absolutely eliminate them seeing a
glowing light slowly approaching from
the other side of the Hill the boom boom
family members get ready to lay their
trap riding closer and having followed
the family's tracks all day Mount blows
out the light on his Lantern and speaks
up to whoever's nearby stating that he
was about to continue tracking them the
next morning and Camp here but under the
law of the United States and Arizona
territory he's been commissioned as an
assistant sheriff and now he's placing
this random under arrest for three
murders during the race he urges him to
slowly walk out with his hands up as
depending on the situation he
technically has the rights to execute
him seeing the man shuffel out backwards
with his hands up Tim tells the man to
keep moving back with those hands raised
but after he sees the fa turn and
realizing that it was Johnny joar who
came in fifth place he's taken by
surprise when Johnny biffs a bloody
horses shho right at him having an
otherworldly prowess over the Rope
though Tim just flexes and catches the
shoe noticing that a bunch of blood
spread off his shoe when he caught it he
curiously tracks down the fleeing Johnny
over to the edge of the thorny
undergrowth patch telling the fleeing
dude that the chase ends here Tim knows
that if he wanted to go around the Brier
patch then the dude would actually most
likely Escape before he could hit him
off not wanting him to get away temples
off his glove and send his lassu forth
into the Maze of thorny bushes Lassing
this random Johnny dude around his neck
Tim asks if he should yank him out or
will the dude comply pulling a knife
from his pocket and attempting to slice
the Rope Johnny is just baffled when he
looks down to see a bunch of hands now
coming out of the Rope grabbing his
hands and stopping him from cutting
himself free looking up and seeing
fingers flying down this wacky ass rope
now the grip is tightened more and more
by Tim before he completely subdues the
man back over with Tim it's Sean that
somehow the Rope has become one with
himself and it's looped through all of
his freaking fingers just to add to the
awareness of the situation Tim merges
his second hand into the rope and sucker
punches the side of this random fake ass
Johnny's face screaming out in horror
over the fact that Tim's fingers broke
into pieces before traveling along the
Rope freely Ben wonders if there's a
possibility Mountain Tim also went to
that specific mountain and became a
cursed man not worried even if this is
the case Ben points out that mount Tim
had touched the Horseshoe throwing
earlier and because of that he's now
indirectly touching him all Ben has to
do now to Ena their plan is escape the
rope's grasp unable to use the knife in
his hand though due to like Tim holding
it back Ben manipulates the skin on his
face to have a blade merge through and
slice the Rope around his neck surprised
with how light his rope just became Tim
quickly reels it in while realizing that
the dude most likely had two knives on
him seeing the enemy's horsse maker run
through it now Tim joins his hands back
together and states that from memory
that dude's name was Johnny joar and
honestly he's surprised that he was the
murderer back over with the Bono family
as Ben reunites with him he explains
that he's also changed his hoof prints
to match that of Johnny's so all that's
left for them now is to let Mount Tim
get ahead and track down Johnny and Garo
himself once he does that the plan is
for all three of these GS to chill out
and watch while all three of the others
get sucked together before exploding due
to the magnetic force so that there
officially brings us to what is the very
end of the desert born Outlaws Arc if
you guys have enjoyed the video so far
and want to see more stuff just like
this before like a multitude of
different series from Demon Slayer to
Tokyo Avengers then make sure to
subscribe and leave a like on the video
as it really helps out with pushing my
content to a bunch of new amazing people
but either way for nowc being your
professional degenerate de and I will
see you all in a BS bye